we're flying at 1900 feet
of the west of scotland on our way to
the only commercial airport in the world
where the runway disappears underwater
twice a day
barrow in the helenan cheer is an island
with about 1200 people and 60 square
kilometers
and the only flat part you can put a
runway on is the beach
coffee tell echo bravo sierra para
information
run me one one language discretion
surface one
one two zero one five knots generally
if you haven't been to bar before you'll
fly over once get a feel for it and then
come in the second approach and
on land we have three active runways
available
we have marker posts to indicate the
center lines of the runway
i can see them from the ground i'm not
too sure if the novice coming in for the
first time can actually spot them
we've got the hills nearby here behind
me sometimes you get the wake of
the wind turbulence off that so that can
make it a wee bit bouncy on the approach
let's say if you walk from a landing
that's a good landing so
so far majority have been all right
basically our operational layouts are
governed by the tide
we don't know the fixed times every day
it's very
flexible on that depending on on the
tide situation but there was quite a bit
of standing water on the beach because
the tides are still going out today
but there's a lot of spray
the beach itself is actually a good
surface nine times 13
passengers actually don't really feel
that they actually touch down because
then they will
gets absorbed into the sand so you don't
get that initial hard
thud and skid well thank you very much
what a landing we're not here to have
control up here in barab
we don't separate aircraft but we give
them a lot of information are similar we
give them the weather
we give them traffic information we give
them clearances but generally your
biggest aircraft is to nutter the
tornado is a nice big fat tire so just
ideal we private ones are narrow ones so
they have to be careful
we give them a warning day after an
engine rev up
try to departure in that and we then
encourage them to do it on the harder
drier sand here because when you vibrate
you can actually vibrate into a
you're stuck so we've had to actually go
and respond and pull them out in the
fire services
with ropes and shovels and pushing and
pulling and all that kind of stuff most
private acre come in vfr which is visual
flight rules
you know you go to whatever height and
direction you go at but
when you've actually got your hands in
the wheel and doing you that's that's
the real fine and that's what they enjoy
but come and go vimbara there are other
beach runways in the world i mean
technically
any beach can be a runway in an
emergency but this is the only one
with an internationally recognized
airport code and when the airport's
closed
anyone can just kind of walk along the
runway because
it's a beach well basically it's a
public beach we have a license from the
cea to
harvest an airport so the only way we
can demonstrate when it's active is to
race and know the windsocks and people
just come from all directions
you get people walking their dogs
tourists wandering on no matter how many
signs i
have and put up around here warning
people the sun will read the sign
and then they'll ignore it and carry on
there's a people up in the tower
watching the beach when their own naked
eye to see
anticipate if anyone strays on the beach
the fire staff is an evidence also keeps
an eye out
wood bottles even stones get washed in
so we have to go and inspect that
there's no
there's no litter on the beach bar
information helps one permission to
enter all runway areas for
inspections
so we try and put as many signs up as
possible to stop people coming but
you'll never stop it
no i guess it's tourists that are the
bigger problem it kind of spit a mixture
of both
and small wading birds although i guess
they can get out the way if they need to
yeah they were your oyster catchers
they're quite powerful around here
fortunately it's quite a clean beach we
get seaweed coming in and we've just
checked to see that sea was okay
there are no rocks or stones attached to
them
i'm just looking at the depth of the
water here that's about
three centimeters the glass that's
flooded
yeah i'm getting wet there i'm bringing
the camera back in
oh yeah it is i'm not we're more than
just an airport we're a tourist
attraction eleven houses and bucket list
even coming to land
but that's the same with pilots
everyone's gonna oh yes i've learned
about airport and taking it and
i always remember coming to borah you
look out and think yeah you are spoiled
in the environment you're working in
and the fact is so unique that it should
be a privilege to
that you were part of it
there's nowhere else
you